do you have a writing routine that you
follow I have two answers for if I have
a writing routine that I follow and one
is yes I have a writing routine too is I
don't always follow that writing routine
the best work I've ever done was when I
followed that routine but some reasons I
I don't follow it all the time and it's
tough and sometimes it's because of just
what else I have going on in my life
that routine that I really liked and
worked for me didn't it's it's just no
longer sort of an option for what I have
going on right now and other times it's
just tough to just sit down at the desk
and write even though I know I already
have a plan to do that
it's just tough you know you don't want
to and so sometimes I don't I fail at
sitting down and writing but when I was
following it it was great and when I do
follow it it's great because it forces
me to write and the routine was
basically I would get up and two hours
in the morning I would write and then
that was it for the day as far as
official writing time I would still pull
out a notebook or if I was really
inspired I might open the computer and
write some more but those two hours I
would set the timer and I would write at
the end of that two hours I would stop
no matter where I was no matter whether
I felt like I could keep going for
another two or I was like thank God I
just I barely made those two hours that
felt like a slog but having it be
time-based told me that it doesn't
matter what I've written as long as I
have shown up and I have written and so
some days those two hours would produce
you know ten pages other days that were
produced one but I was measuring whether
or not I was doing my job by the time I
was spending doing it and not
necessarily the page count or the word
count so I think that so much of what we
do is up here and it doesn't always
translate to
the pages and so that one page that I
wrote over that two hours that might
have been really difficult and was a lot
of thinking and feeling and kind of
moving through what was going on there
and that one page is great output for
those two hours and those other ten
pages I wrote the day before might not
be great so I shouldn't measure my
progress with what was going on the page
but more about the fact that I could sit
down show up and do the job does active
or passive voice come into play with
screenwriting or is it just that's more
with prose I think active and passive
voice doesn't come up in screenwriting
for me I don't know if that's because
I'm just not thinking about that as much
so I'm not sure okay just sometimes you
know they say well don't write in
passive voice and I just wasn't sure
with the rules of screenwriting is it a
faux pas so right and passive voice for
you don't screenplay even if it's just
little like action line but it's not I
think that one of the things that's
great about screenwriting is that there
are no hard rules so if there's a reason
that the passive voice should be used
here for an effect it's permissible like
you can do whatever you want and so I
think understanding why this action line
is better in a passive voice as opposed
to an active voice or vice-versa is more
important than adhering to any sort of
you should never write in the passive
voice you should never do this because
for every rule that was laid out there's
a bunch of examples of it being broken
and broken successfully and I think you
can break it successfully because you
you know why breaking it is going to
produce a greater effect than adhering
to it and one of the freedoms of this
a format is that you have so much room
to break all these rules
you